in today's challenge episode we're gonna
try and split a ping pong ball in half
play with the net filled with hold
and more let's get into it
from the edge
hit the gun
[Music]
[Applause]
a sign for you to hit subscribe
we're gonna try to split a ping pong
ball by hitting it there we did this
challenge five years ago onto a knife
and we got it to stay there if it
doesn't work then this is a great
promotion for our balls
i'm just going to be under here
it hit
it had no effect at all oh dear it just
bounced right off i'm not overly
confident that we'll actually get this
oh
it chipped
take some chocolate and then we'll get
this chocolate racquet guitar chocolate
racket this is a mini chocolate racket
once we hit 5 million subscribers we're
going to make the world's biggest
chocolate racket so make sure you hit
subscribe we had been smashing ping pong
balls at this axe for the last 45
minutes and we were starting to lose
hope so we switched to a knife but still
we were only getting chipped balls and
not the perfect slice in half that we
were looking for got to believe in
yourself there mom we weren't going to
give up we froze the balls for the night
took the blades to be sharpened and got
a blow torch just in case it still
wouldn't split stick until the end of
the video to see the results
[Applause]
i got it i got it back
[Applause]
oh no
that was a roller from here exactly what
i tried
first one to fill their side with ping
pong balls wins and the loser gets to
enjoy one raw pig so disgusting
good luck
i'm so nervous it's disgusting eating a
raw egg no that's going yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
this would be better for me if i didn't
serve at all i'm going to change tactic
thank you
thank you then i put a bit of spin
oh
oh
[Applause]
i've figured out if you go around the
side like
that thanks so much good match
up
it's it's not that bad no
no
the ping pong ball slice is still coming
up so watch until the end
i'm going for a triangle
surprise
i didn't see i don't know i was
oh you got it through
you know this is so much harder than it
looks i think we should make even more
holes
[Music]
emily what do you think about the net
this is strange
obviously
[Music]
yes
yes
sorry
it's so confusing
[Applause]
just in time
now we have a hole
look at my shirts look at my rubber yeah
hey zero zero zero
[Applause]
awesome
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
match point
everybody until next table
it's a new day these balls they have
been into freezer for 24 hours but the
more important thing
we have got the axe and the knife
sharpened by a professional blacksmith
no matter what it takes we're going to
make this happen axe plus frozen balls
start feeding
yeah we've seen this before maybe if we
reach the certain point then it will
just crack open
you know what time it is
the blowtorch
i don't know if it's going to make any
difference but
this has happened before
this flew at me
so we got it we
splitting a ping pong ball not quite in
half
we are pleased but we are not satisfied
i think
we got something it's a mini table juice
racket i think we can get the perfect
slice let's move on to the batman
rockets just to spice it up a bit
yeah it's going a lot harder
it's not perfect but it's good enough
it's good enough but the main thing is
yes
no very good